das wäre eine sensationelle erkenntnis
kommt das leben gar nicht aus dem meer
wie bisher angenommen
ein forschungsteam aus münchen meldet
dazu jetzt einen entscheidenden
durchbruch
es hat nämlich einen neuen reaktionsweg
gefunden also den weg wie aus chemischen
elementen unserer komplizierten moleküle
des erbguts entstanden sind krieg zum
science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen vor etwa vier milliarden
jahren müssen die ersten einfachen
bausteine auf der erde entstanden seien
quasi die vorboten des lebens die
meisten fachleute gehen derzeit davon
aus dass die ersten zellen nicht dna
sondern rna als erb moleküle nutzen also
nicht diese kühl ribonukleinsäure die
doppelhelix die unser erbgut trägt
sondern ribonukleinsäure die noch bei
bestimmten viren die erbinformationen
trägt schließlich braucht rna keine
zusätzliche enzyme um sich zu
replizieren doch diese chemische
evolution die der biologischen
stammesgeschichte vorangegangen ist ist
immer noch nicht im ganzen verstanden
wie können sich die vier
unterschiedlichen bausteine aus denen
dna besteht gemeinsam in der ursuppe
gebildet haben es ist quasi ein eintopf
denen die münchner wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler jetzt entdeckt haben
und der könnte die entscheidende
erklärung dazu liefern wie sich alle
vier bausteine der rna gemeinsam in der
ursuppe gebildet haben bei der erna
handelt es sich um erb moleküle die
anders als sie dna keine zusätzlichen
enzyme benötigen um sich zu
vervielfältigen die meisten fachleute
gehen davon aus dass die ersten zellen
auf der uhr erde aus diesem grund rna
stadt dna als app moleküle nutzen doch
wie sind die bausteine dieser erb
moleküle gemeinsam in einer ursuppe
entstanden forschungsteams weltweit
suchen verzweifelt nach einer antwort
denn das würde einen entscheidenden
schritt der chemischen evolution
erklären das große rätsel basiert darauf
dass die vier bausteine der a2
unterschiedlichen klassen angehören
chemisch gesehen handelt es sich um zum
einen purine und zum anderen um pury
medine bislang wurden reaktionswege
aufgespürt
entweder zu der einen oder zu der
anderen der beiden chemischen klassen
führen demnach können diese 4 nv stand
aber nicht an ein und demselben ort
entstanden sein
denn ihre reaktionswege erfordern
unterschiedliche bedingungen heißt also
der bau der sogenannten pyramiden
gemeint sind insbesondere deren basen
namen cytosin und grazil benötigt ein
anderes geochemische setting auf der
frühen erde als die sogenannten purine
bei deren basen handelt es sich um a
demmin und guanin das ist der stand bis
jetzt doch ein forschungsteam der ludwig
maximilians universität in münchen hat
tatsächlich einen reaktionsweg
aufgespürt durch den alle vier basen
gemeinsam entstehen können hier kommen
wir wieder zum thema eintopfen natürlich
nur bildlich gesehen in der
pressemitteilung der universität ist
jedenfalls von one shot one da die
sprache das experiment der deutschen
fachleute zeigt dass für die synthese
der direkten vorstufen für purine und
pyramiden nicht wirklich komplizierte
bedingungen geben sein müssen auf der
website heißt es dass die einfachsten
chemischen zutaten und
reaktionsbedingungen die sie auf der
erde vor millionen von jahren etwa auf
geothermalen feldern mit vulkanischer
aktivität im untergrund oder aber auch
in flachen teilchen zu finden gewesen
sein dürften dafür ausgereicht hatten
im experiment hatten die münchner
fachleute die bedingungen der ur erde
simuliert und herausgekommen waren die
sogenannten nukleotide dabei handelt es
sich eben um direkte vorstufen für die
purine und pury medine als zutaten für
ihren one pott also eintopf nutze das
münchner forschungsteam substanzen wie
ameisensäure harnstoff und ammoniak also
sehr einfache substanzen hinzu kamen
salze und metalle die in der erdkruste
vorkommen unter anderem nitrit und
karbonate sowie eisen und zink die
chemischen kettenreaktion wurden
angetrieben durch nass trocken zyklen
auf der erde konnten diese
beispielsweise durch regen und
dürreperioden entstanden sein oder aber
durch hydrothermale quellen die
fachleute selbst waren überrascht wie
einfach die reaktions bedingungen
eigentlich waren und doch für die
synthese solch komplexer moleküle
sorgten
dazu der chemiker thomas karall der an
der studie beteiligt war
es gibt wie
einige komplexe moleküle die sich in so
engen reaktion spendern herstellen
lassen ein starkes indiz dafür dass sich
diese reaktion schritte tatsächlich auf
der frühen erde abgespielt haben könnte
die fachleute bezeichnen ihre
erkenntnisse selbst als durchbruch
demnach sind die vier basen der ersten
moleküle also nicht durch zwei getrennte
reaktionswege entstanden sondern durch
einen gemeinsam dafür werden nur wenige
vorläufer moleküle gebraucht und eine
umgebung die ab und an mal austrocknet
diese erkenntnis stärkt die theorie dass
das leben gar nicht im meer entstanden
ist die wiege des lebens liegt demnach
fiel er in flachen tempeln und heißen
quellen die benötigten bedingungen für
diese reaktionen könnten aber auch in
geothermalen quellen die vulkanischen
basieren geherrscht haben dazu schreiben
die us-wissenschaftler in einem
kommentar im gegensatz zu
vulkanausbrüchen oder dem einschlag von
meteoriten die häufig als triebkräfte
der probiotischen reaktion angeführt
werden wären last trocken zyklen
regelmäßige ereignisse auf allen
landflächen der frühen erde
oder anders formuliert nicht nur die
nötigen bedingungen sondern auch die
notwendigen ausgangsstoffe konnte die
uhr erde wohl in den meisten regionen
bieten die studios münchen hat ein
weiteres wichtiges ergebnis selbst dann
nämlich wenn die ersten zellen doch dna
stadt rna als erbmolekül nutzen könnten
die dafür notwendigen basen durch den
nun aufgespürten reaktionsweg entstanden
sein
dazu heißt es in der studie der
reaktionsweg erlaubt die gemeinsame
bildung aller watson kriegt wasen
ja ich finde das immer wieder spannend
wie sich herausstellt wie zwingend die
entstehung von leben hier auf der erde
stattgefunden hat also was für ein
absolut natürlicher und unkomplizierter
weg das war und das ja das stärkt auch
die vermutung dass es auf anderen
planeten auch in unserem sonnensystem
ganz einfach leben geben könnte
bio genese der ursprung des lebens
anklicken anschauen und raum zeit wirkt
der zukunft abonnieren ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran